- Oh, yeah, there's a
couple of studios actually.
Right in around this photo studio.
- [Mark] Cool. All right, so Jack.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Jack, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I was born, bred and trapped
in Boston, Massachusetts.
- [Mark] You're a Boston boy?
- Yeah, yeah, I sure was.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
You grew up with both parents?
- I had a pretty happy childhood.
My parents stayed together,
that type of thing.
I had a good upbringing.
They weren't drinkers or drug addicts
or anything like that.
- [Mark] Yeah, so a
pretty solid childhood?
- Pretty solid childhood.
My dad did get sick when I was younger
and he passed away when I was young,
so that was what was my big blow.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- But aside from that,
a very normal childhood.
- [Mark] And when did you move to LA?
- I moved to LA in the early 2000s.
I went to a vacation in Las Vegas
and it just happened to be AVN week.
I didn't know what AVN was,
I watched porn but I wasn't
really that into the industry.
- [Mark] AVN is the ...
- The Adult Video News awards.
Yeah, it's kind of like our Oscars.
The adult industry's Oscars.
So I found myself in this
casino with all these people
in the adult industry and
I was seein' how much fun
they were havin' and I was
like wow, this is pretty cool.
So it kind of sparked my interest.
- [Mark] And you were how old?
- At that time I was 29, at that time.
- [Mark] Yeah, so you were young.
- Well, young by normal standards
but in the adult industry
it's kind of gettin' old to start.
But I got the idea in the back of my head
and at the time I was
working construction,
hazardous waste removal,
real ball breakin' work,
and just really unhappy with my life
and where it was goin'.
There was a snow storm one
day and I was out of work
and sittin' there watchin' Showtime
with my girlfriend at the time
and I see this documentary,
it's called Pornucopia.
And in it is all these
adult industry figures,
Tommy Gun and Brad Armstrong,
Jessica Drake, Evan Stone,
all these types of people.
And I'm watchin' this documentary
and they're talkin' about how great LA is
and how they all have
this fantastic lifestyle
and they have sex with all these people
and they're paid money
and live in nice houses
and so it's like fuck!
The hell am I doin' in Boston?
So I'm watchin' the TV and
I seen all these people
enjoying this great life
and I look at my girl
and I said what the hell
are these people doin'
that I can't do?
And she said well, for one
they live in Los Angeles.
And I don't know, maybe it
was something with the way
she said it, like they lived
on the moon or something,
like this impossible place I
could never get to Los Angeles
and somethin' about that mentality just,
in the back of my head,
I didn't sleep all night
because it really got to
me and I didn't want to be
one of those people
just trapped in Boston.
So the next day I went to work,
after 12 years I gave my boss my notice,
my two week notice,
and they wished me luck
and I did it, I moved
out here to Los Angeles.
And me and my girl got
into the adult industry
and at the time we were kind of naive,
we thought we could do it together,
just work with one another
and I found out very quickly
that's not how it works here.
But it was good, within a few
month I'd met a few people,
we shot for a couple different directors
and one day get a phone call
and it's someone's birthday,
so director says hey, I'm
gonna swing by in my limo
and grab you, we're gonna go to a club,
it's Tommy Gun's birthday.
Holy shit, that's a big
guy in the industry.
So the limo comes, I've never
been in a limo before (laughs)
I didn't go to my prom or anything.
And the door opens up and
in the limo is Jessica Drake
and Brad Armstrong, Tommy
Gun, all these people
that were in the documentary
that I just watched
three, four months earlier.
I'm like fuck!
I'm not going to say that it was easy,
but it didn't take very long.
I just had to get off my
ass and make a real effort
and come out here and do it.
Then from there I just met so
many great people and yeah,
that's pretty much how
I entered the industry.
- [Mark] And you got an
agent and that led to ...
- I did.
Well, one of the first people
I met also in addition to that
was Ron Jeremy.
And everyone's a Ron Jeremy fan.
I had his movies, my
dad had old stag films
when I was a kid and I
used to sneak in steal
all the VHS tapes.
That's funny, when I was
a kid, a buddy of mine
whose father had a VCR also,
we were the first two guys
in my neighborhood to get 'em,
we would pirate the movies
back and forth on the weekends
when our dads were asleep.
And so even middle school,
I was selling bootleg copies
of Ron Jeremy pornos.
So I told him that story
when I first became friends with him,
he was disturbed by it
because of my age, obviously,
but yeah, it was a real bonding moment.
I knew all these different
movies and stuff,
titles that had been
out of print for years.
I start naming these movies.
Oh, I loved you in Daisy Chain
and this one and that one
and he's going Jesus, how old were you?
So I tell him.
He goes oh man, I feel terrible (laughs)
But he was kind of my mentor as well.
He's the one who explained
to me that you can't
just work with your girl.
Actually, I'll tell you that story,
that's a good one.
The first night I meet him
was on Halloween night 2004,
and it was at the Rainbow
Room down in Los Angeles.
A close friend of mine
met him that morning
and told me hey, he's going
to be at this Halloween party.
So I show up at the Halloween
party, I introduce myself
and my girl, and tell him we
just moved to Los Angeles,
get in the adult industry
and I know a couple people,
common people that we knew.
So at the end of the
night, the club's closed
and he says what are you kids doin'?
And the person I was with
was also kind of like ...
Let's say she's a really close
friend, almost like family,
say a sister for lack of a better example.
So as soon as we say we're
gonna go back to the hotel
we have right down the
street, blah, blah, blah.
And he says okay, well,
I'll hang out with you guys
if you wanna.
I said oh, fuckin' how
cool is that, right?
Hangin' out with Ron Jeremy, fuck yeah.
So we get back to the hotel
and I want to take a
picture with him, right?
But at this time, cell phones
didn't have cameras yet.
This was back in the early 2000s.
So I had one of those digital cameras,
not the new digital cameras,
the old digital cameras
just to say.
So the batteries are dead
and he says oh don't worry,
there's a gas station across the street,
go get some batteries, I'll wait here.
Oh, cool.
I'm not thinkin' at the time
I'm leavin' basically my sister
and my wife in a room with Ron Jeremy,
and I don't know any better at point.
So I go down the street,
I get the batteries,
I'm comin' back, I'm all
set to take my photos
and I open the door and
there's the both of them
suckin' his dick.
(laughing)
And it's just (boom sound)
the reality that hits me,
I'm goin' oh, what the ...
But I thought to myself I should leave,
I don't know, should I leave?
Should I stay?
I don't know what's the right thing to do.
So I put the batteries in the
camera and I thought about it
and I just started snappin'
pictures and luckily,
my sister, she felt
pretty awkward about it,
so she left right away.
Again, not blood sister,
just a very close friend.
Someone I did not expect to
start suckin' Ron Jeremy's dick
in the two minutes that I was gone.
So I took the photos and she left,
my girl and I stayed and
we shot a whole sex scene.
He fucked her, I filmed
it and at the end of it
he looks at me and he
goes you know what, kid?
He goes you might have a
career in this business.
I thought for sure when
you opened that door
you were going to turn
around and walk the fuck out.
And he goes, but the
fact that you were able
to keep your composure and put
the batteries in the camera
and take the photos.
He goes, you might have what it takes.
So that was my first
night meeting Ron Jeremy.
Now I know better (laughs)
- [Mark] (drowned out)
- I say that in jest because
my present girlfriend now,
we sometimes shoot with him as well.
But that's kind of the
guy he is, you know?
But yeah, so he's just
one of the great people
I've met in this industry so far.
Him, Stormy Daniels is
a good friend of mine.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Your first scene
that you did as an actor
in the porn industry was what?
What went through your
mind as you were doing it?
- The first two or three, I
think, they were couple scenes,
so I was doing them with my girl
and they're for very small companies,
like no name, mom and pop companies.
And I just thought it was
cool, you got the feel of it.
It was a little uncomfortable at first
havin' a stranger behind
your ass with a camera
lookin' at the back of your balls.
- [Mark] So your girlfriend
that you were living in
Boston with came out?
- Correct, yeah.
- [Mark] She joined the industry with you?
- Yeah, we were together
for six or seven years.
- [Mark] (drowned out)
- Yeah, totally normal couple,
didn't swing or anything.
We were totally normal and yeah,
it was that one documentary
we both went, fuck, you know what?
We can do this.
And so that was very different too,
now my girlfirend's having
sex with all these other guys
but it's equal, we both
got in at the same time.
Sometimes she'd work more than me,
sometimes I'd work more than her.
So that's the nature of the industry too,
the girls sometimes have
shorter shelf lives,
I guess you could say, than the guys.
- [Mark] How did your male
ego deal with the fact
that your girl was screwing
some other guy all day
and then she's home with you?
- That's a great question, actually.
I had had a bunch of
previous relationships
and it always ended up with
the girl cheating on me,
so I definitely had a sensitive
ego when it came to that,
but again, there's people like Ron Jeremy
and those types.
Once you understand the
nature of the business
and they'd say you gotta let go of this,
you can't just work with her,
you're gonna have to fuck other chicks
and that's a good thing,
and she's gonna fuck these other dudes.
But also what was different
about the adult industry
back then when I started,
and I've had many directors
tell me this back then,
they wanted male talent
to have a girlfriend in
the industry with 'em.
Nowadays, any good looking
guy can just get in there
and an agent will take 'em on.
Back then, you had to have
a girl to go in with you
and the reason being,
just to explain this,
some days I might workin'
with the director's wife
and the next week he might
be working with my wife.
So it was that common respect thing
and I miss that about the
adult industry a lot, actually.
That's changed now.
Like I said, now anybody can show up,
you have people comin' from
all different walks of life
and some people cross
over from the gay side
of the adult industry and
they cross into our side
and it's just chaos all over.
You don't know who you're workin' with,
you don't know what they're
doing in their private life
if they're escorting, if
they're doin' high risk ...
That's the most PC way I can say it.
- [Mark] What is high risk?
- Well, the gay side
of the adult industry,
a lot of 'em don't test.
A lot of performers are HIV positive.
That risk factor's gone up.
They say, according to the
AIDS Healthcare Foundation,
by 60% you increase your
chances of contracting HIV
by working with crossover performers.
And another reason is the escorting.
- [Mark] Oh, yeah.
- That's a big part of it as well.
When I started back in the early 2000s,
I'm not gonna say girls
in the adult industry
didn't escort because
that wouldn't be true,
but it wasn't so widespread.
It wasn't accepted.
I remember there'd be
girls if you found out
they were escorting, I
could put 'em on a no list.
So-and-so I found out's turnin' tricks,
I don't want to work with her
and that was acceptable.
That's all thrown out the window now.
That's all old school thinkin' now.
Now you're some sort of
a bigot or narrow-minded
if you don't to just
put your dick in anyone.
And that part really bothers me.
There's a girl just recently, August Ames,
God rest her soul, she
was a really sweet girl
and she made a choice,
she didn't want to work
with a crossover performer
and she made the mistake
of letting people know
and it got on Twitter and
the next thing you know,
you have top industry
people attacking this girl,
cyber bullying her and she hung
herself that night over it.
She killed herself.
It was all because she didn't want to work
with a certain performer because
she felt he was high risk.
So I wish people weren't so
politically correct these days,
more health conscious and
more hey, you know what?
It is what it is.
If this person's doing
this and they're high risk,
I have the right to choose whether or not
I will work with 'em without
fear of being attacked.
- [Mark] How has your career affected
your personal relationships with women?
Or do you date people in the industry?
- What you really don't do
in the industry, I find,
I couldn't imagine trying
to date a civilian.
That's what we call people
that aren't in porn.
I don't think it would ever work.
Examples that I see of
people in the industry
that try it, it never works.
Say for an example, some girls,
they don't want to date a porn guy
because there's a bunch
of different reasons
we'll get to in a second
but they try datin' outside
the adult industry and in the
beginning the guy's all yeah,
wow, I'm datin' this hot porn
chick, she's got big tits
and she's beautiful and this and this,
and then after a week or two
they start to realize hey,
the girl I'm dating is a porn chick
and she's out there
fuckin' these other guys.
And then they start to get
insecure and that type of thing
and then next thing you
know the girl will have
a promising career, doin'
really well for herself,
will all of a sudden tell her agent hey,
I'm not gonna do boy and girl anymore
or I'm not gonna do this
or I'm gonna do interracial anymore,
that's another one.
Then they gotta catch that
whole raft of shit for that
for being racist.
But yeah, you'll have a girl
with a successful career
and the next thing you know
she's just doing girl-girl
or maybe not even workin' at all.
I call them whore killers (laughs)
That's my pet name for those guys.
But yeah, that's a great
question you ask, actually,
it's tough to be in the adult industry
'cause we have to date
other adult performers
because no one else is gonna get it.
- [Mark] What are the
upsides and downsides
of your career?
- Lately I'm takin' a little time off.
It's good to take breaks in this business
because you can wear
yourself out pretty easy.
So I've stepped behind the camera,
I'm doing a lot of
stuff behind the camera.
It's allowed me to enjoy sex again
because for while, for a long while,
in the beginning of my career,
I was workin' 15, 20
scenes a month sometimes.
It's a lot of work for me.
Some guys work more,
some guys work every day.
I don't know how those guys do it,
they must have Teflon on
their dick or somethin',
I don't know.
But I could never do that.
You can't be intimate with
your significant other
because it's like oh, I
have a scene on Tuesday
and Thursday, when do you work?
Oh, I got a scene Saturday,
oh it's an anal scene
so I gotta prep and all this.
So you're literally tryin'
to plan intimate moments
with your significant other
and it makes it not organic anymore
it makes it not ...
Just that whole intimacy
is just sucked right out
of your relationship.
So I think that's one of
the biggest problems I have
with it, is findin' a balance
of having a good, healthy,
productive sex life at home
with my significant other
and still being able
to go out a few days a week
and really hit home runs
during the scenes.
It's very stressful.
You got thousands of dollars
sometimes on the line.
- [Mark] And for a man
it's a little different
than for a female, I think.
So do you have to take a
drug or something to stay ...
- Sure, sure.
Yeah, that's definitely a big difference
between the guys and girls.
The girls, if they're
not having a good day,
they just gotta put a
little lube on their vagina
and then off they go.
But with a guy, I'm sittin'
there fuckin' limp noodle,
it's a big problem.
Like I was saying a second
ago, you'll be on a set
for someone ...
I go to work one day, any day,
you show up at a work,
maybe something's going on,
maybe you're late with the car payment
or you fight with your girl,
mortgage is late, whatever,
you get that little stress
in the back of your head
and then as the scene
starts you get to it,
your dick's half mast or it's not 100%,
it gets in your head immediately.
What might've just been a little hiccup
has now turned into this in your mind,
just turned into this massive problem
and you're sittin' there
fuckin' just lookin'
to start a fire jerkin' off
and you see the look
on the director's face,
'cause they're payin' for location,
they're payin' for makeup
artists, lighting guys,
cameramen, depending on
who you're shootin' for,
if it's like Wicked
Pictures movie or something,
you could have a $5-10,000
a day fuckin' go to waste
because you can't keep it up.
You know what?
I'll share this one because
people probably won't think
I will share this one but this is probably
one of Andre's favorites.
I was doing a scene for Stormy Daniels,
I was her production manager at the time,
and the schedule got screwed up
and I was supposed to do
my scene in the morning,
because that's when I
work best and get it done
and then have the rest of the
day to be production manager.
Timing got screwed up, I had
to do my scene at midnight.
By this time I was tired,
I'm just not feelin' it
and total limp dick.
Could not get it up at all.
And nothin' against the
girl, she was beautiful,
she was accommodating, all that,
but I'm just pullin' a limp noodle.
So I went to one of the guys on set
and I said hey, do you an extra Viagra?
I need somethin' to help me out.
And he said I don't use a Viagra,
I use Caverject.
So for those of you who
don't what Caverject is,
it's an injectable and it's mostly used
for people who are paralyzed,
people with real ED problems.
So you take this needle and
you shove it in your dick
and 90 seconds later it's
(knocking sound) rock hard.
And it doesn't matter
if you're horny or not,
you just get this rock hard dick.
(laughing)
It's uncomfortably hard
too, it's not a fun feeling.
It's really difficult to come.
You can always tell a
guy who's on Caverject
because his dick'll be hard
as soon as he comes out
of the bathroom and then two
hours after the scene's over
he's still walkin' around
with his dick still hard
(laughing)
and you're like oh, okay,
easy to see what you did.
So back to me, I'm sittin' there
and I've only shot my dick up a few times
throughout my whole
career but I gotta do it.
It's one of these $5000 plus dollar days.
So I'm in the bathroom and I'm naked
and I'm fuckin' gettin'
the needle and I'm nervous.
My hands are shakin' like a leaf.
Fuck, I can't do this.
Fuck, I can't do it!
So I got to go back out
and I said to Stormy,
who was the director, I go hey Stormy,
could you come here for a minute?
So she looks at me and she
says what, I gotta blow you
or somethin'?
Pee on you or somethin'?
Do somethin' kinky?
What the fuck do you expect me to do?
I said no, no, just come
in, I need your help.
So she comes in the bathroom,
and now everyone, the
cameramen, my agent Andre,
he's outside, everyone
can hear what's goin' on
and so I show her the rig
and I said hey, listen,
you've gotta help me shoot my dick up
and she's like what the
fuck am I gonna help you
shoot your dick up for?
I said well, you're the director.
Look at my hands, I'm shakin'
like a fuckin' chain link fence.
I said you've gotta help me.
So she said okay.
She's on her knees, it's
Stormy Daniels on her knees
in front me with this fuckin' needle
and it reminds me all of
a sudden like that scene
in Pulp Fiction.
Go on the count of three.
Like one, two, no, just fuckin' stab it!
Just don't hit a vein.
So she shoots my dick
up and now I'm nervous,
I'm embarrassed as fuck.
Everyone in the building knows
that I'm havin' a bad day
and this is what it's come to.
Then I come out and this miracle drug
that everyone takes,
quadriplegics can take it
and their dick will get hard,
my dick is still 50/50 at best.
Still flaccid.
Oh my fuckin' God.
I was just so stressed.
So Stormy says you know what?
I'll talk to the location
owner, try to work it out,
leave the equipment,
we'll come back tomorrow.
Maybe you can get some sleep in you,
get some food in your stomach,
we'll have a better day tomorrow.
So I said okay, great.
That's embarrassing but I don't want to
keep everyone there all night.
So we do that, I leave, come
back at 8:00 the next morning
and everything's fine.
My dick works fine.
Was a good scene, it was
actually a pretty damn good scene
and the female talent
she was like well jeez,
it's a world of difference, right?
I said yeah, yeah.
So I'm all happy, I'm smiling,
I'm gettin' my clothes on
and Stormy looks at me
and she says what the fuck
are you smilin' about?
I said well, I just did the scene.
It came out really good, I just killed it.
And she goes oh, you
didn't think about this.
She goes, we're over
budget by a whole day.
She says you're the production manager.
She goes, that means you
have to go to the board
and you have to sit in a big
office full of board members,
all the big shots that own the company,
and explain to them why we're over.
So that's what I got to do.
I got to get in the car and
I got to drive over there
and tell all these employers
and all these top guys.
The first thing they did,
the accountant looks at it
and he says we're over
a day, what happened?
And I'm just about to
break the news like well,
and Stormy just blurts
out his dick didn't work!
(laughs) His dick didn't work!
We had to come back and re-shoot it.
So all the guys that were
in the room went oh jeez,
that's terrible.
Wow, I feel bad for you.
It wasn't the end of the world,
but it was one of those humiliating days
where you just gotta
suck it up and go fuck,
am I gonna quit over it?
No.
Am I gonna learn from it?
Hopefully I'll learn from it
but it does bruise your ego
and you just gotta get up when
you fall in this industry,
you gotta get up and
move on and if you don't,
you're not gonna last long.
Everyone has good days
and everyone has bad days.
What's your batting
average, that's what counts.
- [Mark] Excellent.
Well Jack, thank you so
much for talking to me.
- Well, thank you,
thank you for havin' me.
Honestly, if you didn't have other people,
I'd sit in here all day
and talk to you (laughs)
I got tell you a million stories.
- No, that was great.
- Cool.
- Great stories.
- Well, thank you so much for havin' me.
- [Mark] Excellent, thanks.